In Afghanistan, a suicide bomb blast inside one of Kabul's educational institutions...
...killed at least 48 people and wounded dozens of others.
In Italy, the number of deaths from Tuesday's bridge collapse tragedy climbs to 38.
Search efforts for survivors continue.
In Greece, two Greek soldiers who were detained in a Turkish prison are released.
They were held for five months for illegally entering Turkey.
In Israel, a major crossing at the Gaza Strip reopens...
...after being closed for weeks because of violence that left hundreds dead.
Finally from South Korea,...
...the president of South Korea celebrates the 73rd anniversary...
...of the liberation from Japanese colonization of 1945 in a Liberation Day ceremony.